I did something happened tonight okay
what would you have done that you'd
hadn't won waited till next year
no I suppose the ball or in-n-out burger
which is like our staple after award
shows other questions are you guys on
the left
was this always the plan if you want to
propose no but you can't come in and
plan this B obviously if you're a
nominee it's not like I know I'm gonna
be standing there and do it and it's
been if you saw it an interesting couple
of weeks in my life and it became a
thought and and the thought picked up
steam as we got here this was coming it
just the timing just lined up very
nicely and it was a really magical
moment it was and thank you for saying
yes thank you for saying yes go ahead
hi to the proposed bride how did you get
his mother to approve you oh that wasn't
a problem we I fell in love with his
mother the first time I met her before
Glenn and I even got involved so I think
that we both approved each other and
became friends I want to help answer
that one too because my mom just passed
two weeks ago and it's been really a
whole lot of emotion and and and and
things when when my mom used to come
watch rehearsals that the Tony Awards
and Jan was working there at the Tony
Awards I would find Jan and my mom off
in a corner just talking all the time
and to the point where they started an
email correspondence and all that stuff
and and my mom would always say she was
my friend first and and I I adore that I
love that story because she was and and
and that's what makes this feel
bittersweet but really really nice at
this point on your right
you know we've been dragged back here
and thrown all over the place I haven't
spoken to anybody yet on your right um
Leslie Master from Good Morning America
I wanted I was hoping both of you could
walk me through your day a little I mean
it must have been nerve racking to walk
a red carpet with a diamond ring in your
pocket and did you have any idea and
what was going through your mind when
this was all going on because people
were crying back here oh it was like a
regular day for us because we've done a
lot of award shows because he produces
and directs so many and has been
nominated so we're very grateful for
that so today just felt like a normal
day in many ways though I never expected
this I was shocked I will say this that
it's not a diamond ring it's my mom's
wedding ring which to me is more
valuable than the Hope Diamond it's it's
obviously precious to me and yes walking
around on the red carpet like nothing's
happening with this thing sitting in my
pocket was kind of a nerve-racking
experience to be honest with you it was
such a valuable thing sitting right here
but now it's where it belongs
in the middle that was I want to build
on on that question Jan to you did you
have any suspicions and when the camera
was on you it took you a good 10 seconds
I think to react what was that like I'd
had no suspicions whatsoever I I had no
idea and he usually is so eloquent in
his thank-you speeches so I was just so
grateful that he won and I really hoped
he was gonna dedicate the award to his
mother and he did and then some but I
didn't I'm still processing this and you
saw Jane on camera as much as he did I
want to say thank you to Hamish Hamilton
who's directing tonight's show
who took the cue because obviously I
didn't speak to him and he was dominated
against me tonight so I couldn't even
like say hey buddy this might happen
because it was just awkward but Hamish
right on the spot was on her at the
right point I'm so glad to see the the
replay of that
thank you for not playing us off yeah
straight ahead just to the left of the
pole right here yes
you kind of answered some of my
questions cuz I had made a comment to my
friends that only the director of an
another awards event would know how to
pull off a mid awards event proposal how
did you even know that this would it was
to get played off the literally the only
person who had a heads up was my dad
from me acquiring the ring basically but
no and I I thought about if I were able
to call people in production here or
whatever a lot of people a lot of my
friends work in the show but it didn't
feel right with Hamish nominated against
me and I just didn't want to you know I
respect his space too much to to step in
and say hey if I win I might do this you
know so so no no I just thought through
from the point of view of if I was up
here and what would I do
and it came to be - you're right
in the second room Angela Bishop from
Network tennis trainee congratulations
to you both
I'd love to know the honeymoon plans and
have you heard of the Great Barrier Reef
actually that's on the bucket list I
have to say we would welcome you it
would be a lovely place to celebrate
that sounds great
IIIi think this is so new to us I don't
know if we even know timing of anything
at this point but that sounds great I
just like to know what it was like
walking up those stairs and watching
your husband or your now fiance kneel
before that crowd at the Emmys I can't
even put words to it I'm gonna try as I
said he's done so many award shows and I
worked on the Tony Awards for many years
so I'm used to going up and down those
stairs and actually one time I even fell
down those stairs at one show but
walking up it was surreal and it feels
like this is supposed to be the way it
was supposed to be it just feels right
because he was getting an award himself
and as a director and a producer like on
stage with you know his friends and
family around and others gathered around
a television watching and it just feels
right and we always felt right so
I'm I'm beyond ecstatic and there was
not a doubt in my mind that we don't
belong together forever
thank you right here Oh cute
on your left hi I'm wondering as the
director of the Oscars and someone who
just had a magical like TV moment if you
have any thoughts on the Academy's plans
to put below the line categories during
commercial breaks of the show well I
think to expand upon that I think what
we actually want to do is put below the
line proposals during commercials
because it seems to be working so I want
to go with what works yes in the middle
right there yeah bill Kevin II from USA
Today first did you meet while working
on the Tonys we did and did you have a
plan B for a proposal so what was that
to be honest with you there was no plan
B this was a thought that grew and grew
and then just became but if this didn't
happen exactly in this way something
else equally big and surprising would
have happened thank you - you're right
I follow up I'm Nancy dill in New York
Daily News can you talk a little bit
about if it's okay you're history
how long you've been together what year
it was you met on the show 10,000 years
ago we met in 2001 and we work together
we've been together I don't know ten
years or so and it's you know we both
have daughters I have two daughters she
has three daughters so there's nothing
but estrogen in our world which is all
really good but our lives came together
you know because of the Tonys I guess
and
had centered kind of around this this
environment award show environment ever
since in the middle hi question from TV
Guide what Jim what did you exactly do
on the award shows I worked at the
Broadway League and I was the chief
marketing officer for the Tony Awards
thank you
and the last question front row on the
left hi Marissa Sullivan from US weekly
congratulations thank you so I want to
know how will you to celebrate besides
all the parties you mentioned in and out
I think we'll hear more and they will
probably get more parties than we
thought we were gonna hit tonight so I
don't know if we'll make it as far as in
it out but but but honestly how are we
gonna celebrate it's at least to one of
us it's news right now so we haven't had
a chance to discuss but I think we're
gonna celebrate and probably it's gonna
be a long night
congratulations again thank you thank
you really appreciate it